we have been with Daniel Craig since the
very beginning and only ET can take him
back to where it all started I want to
start by showing you this Daniel this is
us with you 2005 to it I don't know a
what are the qualifications of Blaine
bond 5 I don't know about some of them
for them I don't have much of a quality
I have many qualifications myself but
everything I've got something I can
bring to this you don't know how
uncomfortable it is to watch it yeah I
hate watching myself what do you think
you've brought to the character I
clearly didn't have a clue then not sure
I have a clue now all I knew is that I
wanted to come in and do something that
hadn't been done before and Daniel
delivered the names bond James Bond for
hip films and a three billion dollar box
office but Craig's bond journey
immediately faced controversy fans and
critics questioned whether a then
relatively unknown actor was the right
choice critics even complained that
Daniel was the first blonde Bond did it
bother you that you were getting a
little bit of grief from people when you
know when the announcement was made no
take it all in stride
that's right but that quickly changed
once double-oh-seven emerged from the
waves and Casino Royale fans were shaken
more than his iconic martini you know
that's not half bad and that tiny blue
swim trunk flew off the shelves faster
than an Aston Martin
I don't know so what is Daniel see as
the future a bond
there's been talk a woman or an
african-american or black person to
write a person for the job
you know I mean I think that's kind of
what it should be everybody should be
considered I also for women and for
african-american the shipping great
parts anyway listen across the board it
shouldn't have to be bond that takes
that you know it doesn't need to be
bought it should just be need to be
written some good parts
[Music]
[Applause]